hi there steve kaufman here um
talking again about language learning
today i'm going to talk about
collocations
phrasal verbs
and other so-called language hacks
before i do that uh i should say if you
like hearing me talk about language
learning if you have some requests
uh there was a request for me to do a
video in chinese i may just do that let
me know what you would like to hear also
subscribe if you like the channel and
come and visit us at link i should also
point out that i have started a separate
channel here at youtube where i do my
political rants and i'll leave a link
here in the description box all right
for people who study english
we often i mean there are books on
collocations phrasal verbs i have them i
didn't uh didn't bring it here to show
you but i looked through it
and so the idea is presented by language
teachers that somehow if we focus on
collocations and there are many
websites that tell teachers how to teach
collocations
and the same is true with phrasal verbs
get in get off
uh
get it you know and and there are books
with lists of these phrasal verbs and
the idea is that somehow that there is a
special
phenomenon called collocations or
phrasal verbs and then if you somehow
master these then your english would it
will improve i don't believe it
i think it's it's one thing to focus on
something that
is
performs a particular function in a
language like
so-called modal verbs would could should
might yes it's a good idea to study
those in some kind of concentrated form
so you get a sense of the pattern of how
those are used
in
in romance languages it's a good idea to
concentrate at times on the subjunctive
or in slavic languages on verbs of
motion because those are specific
functional
patterns very defined but
collocations which means by the way is
is sort of
words that normally are used together
or phrasal verbs which is a form of
collocation because certain
verbs are used with certain prepositions
and they have a certain specific meaning
these are potentially endless and i
don't think if you read a book of
collocations or a book of phrasal verbs
that you will retain much rather it's a
matter of paying attention when you are
listening and reading and getting used
to hearing certain words used with other
words sorry i got a funny chair here uh
getting used to this
and and of course if you're on link you
save phrases you say phrases that you
think are are useful to you many of
these phrases will be
collocations words that are normally
used together and in fact that link if
you save a word you will see a number of
phrases that other link members have
saved and some of those might be useful
phrases for you to save and as you save
these phrases and maybe review them in
flashcards and notice them in different
contexts when reading or listening
you'll start to have these chunks that
you can use and these chunks may well be
what some of the language teachers would
call collocations or phrasal verbs but
really
there's no shortcut there's no hack in
order to get used to using these uh
phrases effectively you simply have to
do a lot of listening and reading so
that's my take on collocations phrasal
verbs and other language hacks
thanks for listening bye for now
you